يتوقعوا التوتر في كثره دائما في الشمال
لكنه جاء هذه المره من الجنوب هذه مدينه
شيبسي في جنوب كسوفه واغلب سكانها من
السرب كما في الشمال هنا اطلق جندي من
قوات الامن الكوسوفي النار على اثنين من
الصرف احدهما طفل في الحادي عشر من العمر
والجريحان اللذان قالت السلطات ان اصابته
ما لا تهدد حياتهما من اقليه الصربيه هذا
اسوء ما يمكن ان يحدث في كثره وما يؤدي
غالبا الى موجات جديده من التوتر وقعت
احتجاجات هنا ومحاوله لقطع الطريق بين هذه
المدينه الصغيره وباقي كتبه تم احباطها
بسرعه
اقوى العبارات وقال انه استهدف مواطنين من
كسبه
تعتبروا سلطات كريشتينا كل قاطن كسب
البالا وسربا مواطنين لكن كثيرا من السرب
يدينون بالولاء لصربيا في كتب يعيش نحو
مئه الف من الصلب يشكلون اقليه في البلد
الصغير الذي لا يزيد عدد سكانه عن مليون
و800.000 سنه نصفهم يعيشون وسط وجانب
البلاد وكثير منهم يقبلون التعامل مع
مؤسسات الكسوف
لكن من منطقه الشمال التي يقطنها نصف سكان
من الاقليه الصربيه هي مصدر القلق الاكبر
لسلطات برشينه فهنا لا يخفي السكان
القريبون من حدود صربيا ولائهم لها وهذا
ما يسمح بالقرد بتقتل مستمر على سلطات
بروشينا فمن ذو اعلان كسوف واستقلالها عام
2008 بعد حرب من انتهت بتدخل
النيتوربيا لتوقيع اتفاقات تسمح بالوضع
الحالي لكنها ما زالت تعتبر
الان من ترابها وسكانها السرب مواطنيها
وهذا ما يؤدي الى ازمات متلاحقه في الشمال
اخرها الشهر الماضي بعد اعلان شروطات كسوف
قرار تغيير لوحات السيارات القديمه
الصادره قبل اعلان دوله كوسوفو باخرى
محليه ما ادى الى استقاله عدد من الصرب من
شرطه كسبه وبعد اعتقال شرطيين منهم اقام
سربوكسه حواجز مناعه التنقل بين صربيا
وكثبه انتهت الازمه الاسبوع الماضي وفتحت
الطرق لكن طريق حل ازمه كسوف ما زال طويلا